if you go to your fellow workers and say
I would like to be paid 500 times more
than you so I can have my own spaceship
and I'm also not going to do very much
except sign off on Final decisions
that's probably going to be a hard no
[Music]
we're going to start by talking about
whether social hierarchy is in itself
unavoidable and Ben you're the one who
in the panel who's come closest to a
sort of whether it's Democratic
Socialist or Marxist view of society in
which we're much more equal than we are
now but even in communist regimes
there's a huge amount of social
hierarchy isn't there you know party
members get better Flats than non-party
members
yeah well I don't actually think that's
a great model I mean if the uh if the
question is if the question about
whether we can have a better kind of
society than we have right now is can we
recreate East Germany I would vote no
let's not do that right uh but I happily
I don't think the choices are East
Germany or the sort of uh late
capitalist hellscape that we have right
now you know I think there are other
options and I think there are real life
precedents for other options you know we
can look at things that have been
successfully beta tested under
capitalism uh National ownership of
certain industries I would point out
Health Care in this country you know
which has been wildly successful uh in
many ways
um you know so much so that even
conservative politicians have to pretend
to not want to get rid of it entirely or
else they would never win another
election I would point to a successful
worker cooperatives like the Mondragon
Federation in Spain so I think there are
real life precedents that show that
other things are possible you know if
you put the if you put these elements
together in a different way now can you
get rid of hierarchy entirely I think it
depends what you mean right so if
hierarchy means there are functionally
certain people who have the ability to
make certain decisions that no I think
any you know I mean anybody who's ever
been to the kind of meeting where people
are supposed to do you know jazz hands
instead of clapping and you know come to
consensus and everything probably has
wanted to kill themselves after a few
minutes of that
I don't Advocate that as a model for
anything you know I think you do need a
certain amount of operational hierarchy
in practice that certain people are
empowered to do things and you know make
decisions but I think it needs to be
paired with Democratic accountability I
think that's the uh I think that's the
key point that the Jimmy Democratic
accountability within the organization
or politically at a national level yeah
uh both I think that I think that within
organizations I think Democratic
accountability is good I think if you
you know I think if you look at
decisions for example made during covid
about
um you know when people had to go to
work in what ways and all that stuff you
know you can see some really bad effects
of
um the people who these decisions most
affect not having very much say in them
uh and you know and look again if
hierarchy just means that anybody has
more of anything than anybody else
sure right I think that they you know
even in a worker Cooperative you don't
have completely where everybody gets to
vote on wage scales you don't have
completely flat wage scales you know
that you have some people being paid
more than others for all sorts of
reasons you know here's something you
want me to do that involves a lot of
stress and responsibility you know I'd
like more money if I'm going to do that
here's something that I'd like to do get
a vet you're asking me to do that's
really dirty and dangerous right I'd
like more to do that both of those are
totally legitimate but you're just not
going to have given that Democratic
accountability you're just not going to
have
the level of inequality that you have
within the kind of economy that we have
right now if I if you go to your fellow
workers and say I would like to be paid
500 times more than you so I can have my
own spaceship and I'm also not going to
do very much except sign off on Final
decisions that's probably going to be a
hard no okay so you're happy with some
hierarchy but just a flatter one
basically okay and namaine I'm playing
devil's advocate here by the way
um uh no I mean you're talking about how
University educated people are sort of
unduly rewarded on the other hand if you
want to persuade people to spend three
four for some profession seven years of
their lives in academic training for
that profession surely be able to be
more rewarded for it afterwards because
they're not earning money during that
time whereas people kept picking up the
knowledge on the job or at least being
paid while they're getting the knowledge
yeah I don't I don't think we shouldn't
be rewarding uh University study by any
means because I think there are
um you know there's there's lots of
skill and and you need to go to study
certain for certain jobs you launch our
brain surgeons trains don't we well I
mean but I I guess we're looking at um
at what
um the rewards that aren't there for
those people who haven't taken that path
and perhaps making it more yeah
Equitable where we can
um and and I don't think that um our
current system where uh knowledge gained
in that way is
um is rewarded higher is is going to you
know take us into the next Century or be
able to kind of
um
provide us with a kind of framework by
which we should be looking at how we can
make a more Equitable Society because I
think
um it's it just doesn't work for
everybody
does any society work for everybody well
I think I'm going to Chuck in
um another line of thought which is a
group of people for whom none of this
works are people who are undocumented or
illegal and who have crossed the border
possibly with extremely good reason in
fact in my experience as an MP with the
highest immigration caseload in the
country I would say mostly with
extremely good reason and usually with
legal cause but are pushed out of a
system such that
those jobs which people have now walked
away from in the documented legal Market
will be filled eventually probably by
illegal undocumented low security low
pay poor conditions so they will not be
able to say to an employer you want me
to do this dirty dangerous work I want
more money they'll probably just be
going I'm grateful for the work and be
exploited they will be doing right now
if you if you ask yourselves where all
the baggage handlers at airports you can
tell this to stuck a chord with me this
week
um did you try to fly somewhere this
week try and fail tried and fail and you
can see that actually they because it's
also on the Eurostar by the way and you
can see that there are are these are
places in the labor market where there
will remain gaps if in order to take up
employment in an airport or the aura
star terminal you do have to be security
checked but in those other jobs such as
being an Uber driver or one of the
cycling delivery companies or the
grocery delivery companies they will be
an attraction a pool factor for those
who are undocumented if nobody else
wants to do those jobs and they don't
have the same sort of power
to demand better working conditions
um those that so that that illegality
framework also needs to be placed on top
of also the gender framework which
nemoan rightly put there which is that
the jobs that we have traditionally
undervalued that are sometimes it turns
out they are skilled but we just didn't
think of those as skills
traditionally have been dominated by
women and that has continued what we can
now add on to that not just gender but
also race and migration status that
creates an underclass of people who are
very vulnerable to being very exploited
and will have little say in whether or
not they ever get a decent job or decent
pay and actually sectors that become
feminized it's not just ones that
started feminized but but Industries and
sectors that become feminized see
relative pay rates fall yes which I
think is really interesting
if they do I mean
I'm in a country is that of prostitution
or the paid sexual exploitation of women
and in the Netherlands when that was
legalized around the turn of the century
um the argument was made this is a form
of work like any other when it is
legalized it will be regularized those
women will then form unions they will
demand better paying conditions from
whom I wonder and in fact what happened
was women's choices the Dutch women's
choices were opening up anyway in other
careers so over the course of the last
two decades that so-called job like any
other has come to be dominated by
undocumented illegal or otherwise
vulnerable women marginalized women
trafficked women in particular and For
Whom the legal structure all it's done
is legalized their their exploitation
which is yeah I'm going to add another
layer on top there yeah that's right
um but coming back to the sort of
baggage handler problem we might use a
sort of shorthand and the great
resignation isn't the market just going
to sort this out aren't we just going to
have to it's already starting to happen
in Care Homes isn't it you know there's
such a shortage of carers thanks to
brexit thanks to covid that they're
actually going to have to be paid more
well but are they I mean at the moment I
haven't seen any move from central
government and I do watch them rather
closely who are saying yes we will now
give more money to local authorities
when they purchase care from a care home
I've not seen that happening all I've
seen is local authorities continue to be
underfunded so although
um there are moves to say yes we should
have better paying Care Homes where's
the money coming from is a question
that's not yet been answered Okay so
we've been talking about the underpaid
let's talk about the I'm using air
quotes over paid are they overpaid
um
are we overpaying professional and
management roles given the amount of
work that people have put into getting
to those positions in the first place
and the responsibility they then have to
carry yeah I mean I think it depends on
the job but I would also point out you
know even with the examples as Extreme
as as brain surgeons and I think it is
worth keeping in mind that the vast
majority of people with upper middle
class jobs are not brain surgeons uh
don't have that level of contribution to
society uh but even within a job it's as
Extreme as that I mean since you know
paying one person more means paying
somebody else less you know there is
actually you know there are finite
resources to uh to go around
um then the question is well is not
necessarily is it illegitimate for even
the brain surgeon to you know to get a
little bit more if that's what you need
to incentivize people to be brain
surgeons it's is this level of
inequality actually justified by uh by
the need for those incentives and I'd
also point out that you know part of the
setup you know when you're talking about
brain surgeons even you know it's about
how well they're not making money
during all of these years okay well
that's a fixable problem right there
have been societies and can be societies
where people are paid you know to uh to
attend schools especially if their
attended School become brain surgeons
you know they uh we can we can give them
salaries during that time I I also think
it's at least an open question whether
um in a society where everybody had
their basic material needs met in a much
more adequate way how much just the
value of social Prestige would be enough
to get people to want to do these jobs
and I think there is some evidence for
that you know we like there are a range
of societies historically and right now
where some of these pay gaps are bigger
or smaller than others and it seems like
people still want to do the more High
Prestige jobs where oftentimes they're
doing more interesting tasks have more
control over what they're doing all
things that tend to appeal to human
beings I mean like I don't have specific
statistics on brain surgeons but you
know the uh the society in the world
with the high with the best doctor to
Patient ratio is Cuba and you know and
I'm fairly sure that's not because you
know Cuban doctors are paid more
extravagantly than there are anywhere
else
in more socialist society it was a more
egalitarian societies I should say
perhaps like Scandinavian countries
is it that there are narrower pay
differentials or is it just that taxes
are higher because taxes are definitely
much higher which enables them to pay
for you know
higher benefits and better child care
and all the things that you would want
well I think some of each uh that you
know I mean certainly a large tax fund a
welfare state is a good thing and you
know and uh and I'm all in favor of it
but also I don't think that you would
get those in the Scandinavian countries
without incredibly powerful labor unions
that have you know again without which
you just would not have achieved that
kind of welfare state that have you know
to a certain extent right I don't want
to exaggerate I don't want to
romanticize societies that you know are
not as fundamentally different as we may
sometimes talk about them as being but
you know to a certain extent have
equalized uh wage levels in certain
things like you know they'll engage in
sectoral bargaining right so the union
Federation is bargaining for wages
across you know across the entire sector
of the economy which is the sort of
thing that at least to an extent and at
least within certain areas uh does
equalize wage levels so I would argue
the two go together
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas